thank you
foreign
okay
foreign
foreign
[Music]
things that did seem out of sight
[Music]
every time I hear that theme song ring
if they wanna sing
foreign
[Music]
University of sinks and showers elements
and bathrooms
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
with documents that Donald Trump
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dump
s
and bathrooms Duty
Duty bathrooms God bless
magnitude
oh
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
I'll find his regime my bag of mangoes
now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
back down
[Music]
[Applause]
the Wisconsin crowd
Ed
and Highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
Alex Jones is
very very upset with me
that is a freaking press director who
thinks he's smarter than you think she's
better than you and he's gonna beat you
Pac-Man never talked to the new award
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
telling our children who not to be it's
happening
[Music]
you're smarter than you
Evil's growing is coming what you F4 is
now at the door scratching so open the
door and prepare to meet your destiny
that is a freaking prep director
thinks he's smarter than you
think she's better than you and he's
gonna beat you
well welcome everybody we have an
incredible event on our hands this
evening I actually am so desperate to
see it that I decided to wear my glasses
so I can actually have some idea what on
Earth is going on here I even shaved
it's like a completely different person
is here which is really something else
uh I actually don't really know where
we're going to even watch this debate
the debate is Beto O'Rourke the
Democratic Challenger to the current
Texas Republican Governor Greg Abbott a
horrible person and a terrible Governor
quite frankly very few accolades to his
name the
um so we are monitoring a number of
different things there's this article as
some might call it called five ways to
watch the debate
um it lists NBC 23 cbs4 in Spanish
Valley Central but this is Valley
Central so I found this live stream page
is there any audio is this muted it is
muted let's see
okay so hopefully it'll pop up here it
also lists the Valley Central app now
that redirects to this page and so we're
monitoring this as well and my hope is
that between all of these different
things we're ultimately going to get the
stream at some point and it starts in 25
minutes so we're going to set the stage
we're going to look at elements of
polling momentarily and so many
different things I have new songs to
debut we might hit 1.5 million
subscribers Tonight on YouTube which I'm
going to get to in a moment it's just
such a long list of things and then
tomorrow night we have a trump rally
so I actually believe well let me I want
to get ahead of myself okay let's let's
take a step back on that but we're going
to stand by
um I can't take any more time before
just extremely aggressively thanking
Espress for kicking us off with 50
gifted subscriptions on Twitch already
making such Headway towards our goal of
150 I also want to say thanks to
gingerdale Jen here Harry dirt nap pizza
man pee weasel life is good broken
psyche blueberry babe and Eat the Rich
which kicks us up to 60 see missile puts
us at 61 and really importantly Alma
Castillo just signed up at
joinpakman.com oh and something is wrong
with my Super Chat element
wait a second
see if I can fix this
there we go uh Alma Castillo just signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number 62. folks we are well on our way
to an incredible evening with peace and
love and so many different things so
welcome everybody everybody come on in
let's take a look at the polling is this
a close race that we are going to be
taking a look at tonight well it's not
as close as I would like if you take a
look at the real clear politics polling
average Greg Abbott the incumbent
Republican radical is currently leading
by about eight points does this mean we
don't vote no it doesn't mean we don't
vote does this mean we throw this into
the toilet and flush it 10 to 15 times
no it just means it's we're at a
disadvantage okay but we still have to
fight for this one because it would just
be
incredible incredible to see Beto
O'Rourke defeat Greg Abbott and let's
see let's see if tonight's debate does
anything if you want the most optimistic
case I guess you say it's like seven
rather than an eight point lead
I don't know
but listen well let's be realistic the
polling is not exactly like wow big
party for Beto it's gonna be a tough one
it's going to be a tough one and we are
monitoring all of it very closely and
I'm assuming very soon we are going to
have a debate that uh debate stream that
goes live let's see what we have here
this takes us
to the same page
they seem to be really reticent to
actually link the live stream
but
we're monitoring all of these different
things and I think very very soon we're
going to make pretty pretty significant
Headway on this thing blue man says you
have a live one
uh can you describe where
is that blue man
it's great that you have it
but I would need you to help me find it
if you want to be useful to the stream
now you can't paste links uh you have to
describe it yeah and I don't I don't
have TV in Texas I don't live in Texas
unfortunately so that for people saying
just turn on the TV in Texas I can't do
that
uh
if someone can describe how to find that
live stream I will gladly gladly gladly
go to it but it seems not everybody is
totally totally clear on it super chat's
coming in where would we be without
David Pacman we would be lost
true
David once Mike Lindell actually goes to
court over all of his insane Shenanigans
are you going to cover the pillowcase
for us absolutely over 50
by the machines yep that's true we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
thank you that's all going it's all
happening
uh go to the Texas Tribune okay Texas
Tribune
let's see what they've got
um
let's see
they have a link
I don't see the feed but we can add that
let's add that to our list as well okay
watch live
7 P.M Central
Texas Tribune will live stream the
debate here oh okay that's good I like
that
viewers won't see a video feed until it
starts okay good I think between all of
these things we're going to have it
houstonpublicmedia.org is another one
that people are talking about
uh uh let's see watch that live
oh okay that actually that's a pretty
solid feed guys I think we're going to
be up and running yeah look at this
pre-show starting shortly
and do we have audio
okay this is really good so the other
thing I'm going to do is let me just
create a uh better looking
see if I can do this
just so we've got it all happening
here we go
and then there this working okay for
people and then we'll just do a little
there we go
all right
so we got that
okay looking good all right guys so
we've got this is I think this is good
this is looking pretty strong from the
standpoint of a stream I want to say
thanks to Kevin gouldi for gifting a
subscription on my website your new
member number 63 it is an ambitious but
doable goal today of 150. all right now
I have something incredible to debut for
all of you
not long ago we debuted a new song and
then after I debuted the song Someone
made a video for it okay and I'll just
play a little bit of that for you here
it'll take me away but this is the new
song and the new video from two
different views
[Music]
something's
something
[Music]
okay anyway you guys get it so so it was
that song I have a new song for you guys
and what we need next is a video for it
are people ready for this this is a
brand new song another one that has been
created for the show
exclusive debut exclusive
people are ready okay it's just audio
for now remember it's just audio this is
from casual divide check this out
are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know of a guy who fits
that build up aggressive with political
will but David that's great
if you like to watch some interviews
from a wide array of different views I
know of a guy who gets it done he's
turning learning into Fun
[Music]
membership now for the
bonus.com you get priority on your disc
or call Future notifications or The
Bling and cause aggravation foreign
[Music]
all right so this is it this is it
anybody who wants to make a video for it
it will likely if it's good make it into
the stream intro videos okay so and if
you think that it's slow that the tempo
is slow just speed it up just speed it
up you can just speed it up it'll make
it faster and shorter okay so that's
casual divide David Pacman see Shanty
you can find it on Soundcloud under
soundcloud.com casual divide and I would
love love love for people to do some
um video to go along with it I think it
would just be so extraordinary so
extraordinary okay uh super chats a
couple more Kratos Orion says did I hear
Walgreens was sued by the EEOC for
denying leave to a diabetic pregnant
worker who miscarried I did not hear
about that but I will research it it
sounds despicable
indoor Hydroponics says David I find the
candidate interviews gold these
candidates running for office are
certifiably insane they really are they
really are
I think I'm in the right place this is
the Sam Cedar stream right I see the
familiar glasses and background that's
exactly right this is majority uh the
majority report
the majority Report with Sam Cedar I do
want to say thank you to Jeremy
riddlesperger who is new member number
64 today also thanks to Margot Cabot
Shannon Emily and mums as well as shot X
Thomas Charles Weiland erroneous anir
banbag Chi and the Yamashiro and black
white Rook folks we are at 73 and the
debate hasn't even started yet which is
absolutely extraordinary
absolutely extraordinary stuff uh oh
also thanks to Desiree Delong for
gifting a subscription you're number 74.
beautiful we're in uh we're in pretty
good shape here okay other things that I
have for everybody
um couple video clips yeah that I wanted
to take a look at
Newsmax has started doing a man on the
street type segment I have not
pre-screened this but I'm told it's a
giga cringe let's take a look this week
we wanted to know from you folks out
there right if you thought it was fair
for the three-time failed presidential
candidate to compare Trump supporters to
Nazis our producer Nico Romano asked
that question I'm sure this was very
fairly done so the folks told him
Hillary Clinton compared president Trump
and his rally supporters to Hitler is
that fair no it's not fair well four is
a very overzealous statement for her to
make she should know better than say
things do you think she's saying that
because maybe she wants more Republicans
attacked yeah yeah you know she's it's
like she's trying to like like create
the The Narrative like she's behind the
camera you know what I mean because on
how that he wants to start World War
Three who told you he wants to start
World War Three the media what media
uh Twitter Twitter
told you he wants to start World War III
and what accounts told you that
um like the news on the TV and like CNN
MSNBC yes
it's like a character assassination yeah
it seems like there's a Witch Hunt
against him he's Savage witch hunts have
no shame no morals no conscience and do
you think he should be compared to
Hitler like like how Hitler was because
Hitler killed six million Jews
so a lot of people during the pandemic
because he didn't do anything and
President Biden's doing something about
the pandemic uh yeah cause it's over
right now we're all backing on the
streets I'm not wearing a mask right now
would you say that's due to the vaccine
yeah I would you know he's the one who
rolled the vaccine out right thank you
if you honestly think that their Nazis
are here today I think you've got
another thing coming Donald Trump was a
good president
excellent president now we got Joe
Button Joe Biden right now I know he's
sleeping right now you know what's going
on office oh Donald Trump's a good
president you think it's going to
negatively impact the Democrats
absolutely because all right anyway I
don't know that we need the last 40
seconds that's pretty bad pretty pretty
bad so
yikes that's uh
that's certainly something as we stand
by here for the better O'Rourke debate
against Greg Abbott what it what a
nightmare what a nightmare let's see
what other streams we have or we may
have available to us
uh oh here's another one let's see watch
is this better I mean on what what the
energy is like between both candidates
and everyone can see that for themselves
all right so we've got a bunch of
different streams happening right now
this one and then over here all right
good good good good so I think we're
going to be in good shape as far as the
streams are concerned so that's an
excellent thing excellent excellent to
see that all right let's continue
looking at a few other things because I
do have other things I have some
Herschel Walker content for us here in a
31 second answer about the Atlanta
Braves potentially changing their name
Herschel Walker says talk about 11 times
that's that's once every three seconds
is that possible that uh Senator one I'd
like to talk about because he don't want
oh let me turn it up so that was one
hold on let's start over
yeah Center one I'd like to talk about
because he don't want to talk about
inflation you don't want to talk about
crime he don't want to talk about the
Border you don't want to talk about men
and women's sports those are things that
he voted for so it's one of those issues
so he's turned his bike on the Braves he
turns his bike on on men and women and
blue he turns his bike on Border Patrol
because he don't want to talk about
those things and uh that's all those are
the things that we should be talking
about not whether the brave should
change their names because they have
nothing to talk about when they don't
have anything to talk about they're
going to talk about me they're going to
talk about everything else that uh
Senator one I'd like to talk about
because he don't want to talk about yeah
that was I mean that was it that was
loving
that was 11. I would have I would not
have believed it if you said hey David I
have a video of Herschel Walker saying
talk about 11 times in 31 seconds but he
somehow did it no guys number 12 was the
video started over I know some I thought
the same thing but the V that was it the
video looped automatically so it was
actually 11.
all right
um next Herschel Walker clip here he is
on the campaign Trail referring to
uh multiracial people as mutts
but you know what
all you and my family
you know I'm not going to let my family
get hurt
I've been fight for my family I don't
care what color you are
I told people I got white people in my
family I know you can't believe that can
you
I ain't got black people in my family
I hate you
got all I got everything
I even got a Russian girl in my family
can you imagine guys my nephew was in
the military man with this beautiful
Russian girl
but she's giving me three beautiful
little nephews
and I love every last one of them I said
we're all months
12 months I hate to tell you something
because 23 amen school girls all of
y'all mothers too
but one thing I know about uh
one thing I know about us is we're all
Americans
[Applause]
inspirational speaker as you can of
course see all right just one more
Herschel Walker clip this one's from
earlier uh like a couple hours ago where
he seems confused about what Redemption
means to see if you can figure out the
confusion here even though Sandcastle
first stone right now they've had been
running Those ads uh since I decided to
run and right now with the raised Man
versus the Todd I wanted the people to
see who I am because as I said I believe
in Redemption I believe that people can
be forgiven you know Center one eye is
also voting to uh he want to let people
out of prison well why do you want to
let prison people out of prison and he
don't believe in Redemption wouldn't
letting them out of prison be the
Redemption
I don't even know what he does he even
know what he's talking about I mean he's
gonna make a prison in our own home so I
think Senator why not has to explain to
the people of Georgia
wow
it's it's
humiliating to the United States as a
country that that is even a race
it's it's a humiliation you go to any
country you go here's the two people
running oh look Raphael Warnock he has
so many interesting views about
different issues and proposals and
understands policy and wow it just seems
like a good guy
here's the person running against him
what do you expect the polling to be I
don't know like 90 to 90 to 8 with two
percent undecided no it's like very
close to tide actually and in some polls
Walker's winning what
what
complete and total humiliation just just
doesn't make any sense whatsoever
let's get back to some super chats I do
want to say thank you to Kev multi-beast
Billy Carpenter the freak and then P
Funk apocalypse gifted five
subscriptions and then of course we have
herselfat that puts us at 84. folks we
have a coupon code that coupon code is
indict
the best thing you can do with that code
is get a membership at joinpakman.com
okay this is so easy it's so easy you
hit the sign up button it's it's we
should make it more difficult quite
frankly you type in indict
and you just get a beautiful discount
and if you want like the super secret
unpublished discount you can use the
coupon code Obama see that and you'll
see it's like an even crazier discount
today's a beautiful day to do it it
really is and we are standing by just
six minutes away from the start of this
debate which I think will be
extraordinarily interesting super chats
coming in Jake says hello so you're
looking fresh could we get a public
release of the sound board when you get
to 1.5 million subscribers I don't know
that I can do that by the way I do have
some new things on my soundboard thanks
to some people who sent these in people
were starting to come that was a crazy
moment in the last Trump uh Speech and
then we have this one but he's gonna
represent you long and hard yep and then
also Trump made a very interesting
declaration about the country we
that was a really weird moment
really really strange moment
I did not really understand that
uh
very very weird hey if everybody says
that there's a problem just refresh
because everything's fine with the
stream just refresh the stream and I
think you'll probably be fine I think
everybody will be fine all right here's
where we are on the fight for 1.5
million okay some of you aren't going to
believe this
we could get to 1.5 million tonight we
have so many different things that
people have promised like for example if
we get to 1.5 million by like October
21st there's a guy who's going to make a
mural for the show down in I forget
where
if we get to 1.5 million on YouTube by
October 5th there's a guy who's going to
get a Mount Rushmore tattoo and I'm
going to be one of the faces if we get
to 1.5 million by October 4th I'm gonna
do the Yom Kippur fast I've already made
a beautiful order at a deli to break the
fast let me see if I can find it here
um
let me take a look the order was just
blintzes and anyway I can't find my Deli
order but the whole point is
we're only 1600 away
we could do this right now we we could
get to the 1.5 million right now which
would be completely insane
so consider it okay consider it I'm
selling you nothing other than a good
time but we could completely do it
tonight
um we will get back to that we will get
back to that as the uh debate is about
to happen I need 1600 votes give me a
break
Lindsay is going to make a phone call
Lindsey Graham to see if they can find
me the uh find me the the votes I need
David as I did with Walgreens CVS is now
being investigated by the Rhode Island
Department of Labor for not paying time
and a half on Sundays all right very
good I'm not super familiar with Rhode
Island labor law but it sounds complex
there's an even better coupon code
elements of bathrooms is that actually a
coupon code let me try that hold on
elements of bathrooms
oh my God it is that's crazy kg knows
better than I do what the best coupon
code is all right well there it is
elements of bathrooms
is the uh
is the next is the most explosive coupon
code I guess we will say that is wild I
didn't even know about that
um in all seriousness thank you to S
Prez for gifting another 50 50. that's
five zero subscriptions
John hagger says was little baby rivka's
first word mama or sir no my daughter is
too little to be talking
um
but sometimes she's accidentally said
words like as she is exploring speech
and trying to use uh use it to
communicate a couple times we were
driving around and once I could have
sworn I heard from the back seat dad
but I know it wasn't because nobody uses
the word dad around her and I speak to
her exclusively in Spanish and she was
like two weeks old so clearly it was
just like an accidental utterance and
then the other day I could have sworn
that she said it was like the word in
Spanish for a swing is amaka and I could
have sworn that I heard Amma akka from
the back seat again these are just
accidental utterances
um and then once she yelled out a gay
and I was like oh my God this is I
really hope that she's not homophobic
but again it's just playing with with
words but she did yell out a gay and I
was like what is that about that was
weird
um and everybody heard it too they were
friends over and people like did she
just say a gay I was like she did but it
doesn't like mean anything just
is these are just utterances that's all
it is
um okay oh people are saying we've got a
big dump of memberships yeah they're
slowly listen guys it's people are like
David do you think you will get to 1.5
million tonight I have no idea it's up
to you
I have no idea
it we're we're certainly approaching we
are now down to
uh uh
1617 1 616 1 615 to go
uh We're Not Gonna what 1614 that's
beautiful yeah I don't I don't know I
mean it would be great if it happened
tonight if not maybe uh tomorrow night's
stream
David sir the statement you're making
with the glasses is incredible no one
knows glasses better than Pac-Man yeah
the other thing I thought of is kind of
doing it like this you guys know about
this look
you know about this thing like the uh
I don't even know what you would call
this
but that's that's a whole other thing
that we could look at we could look at
doing that David sir since it's almost
2023 do you think it's time to retire
the coupon code better 21. we never
really yeah this is the Chuck Schumer
are you guys gonna uh codify Roe v Wade
and then he like says yes but obviously
they're not with his glasses down
um we let the coupon codes just run
that's the reality all right let me
thank people gifting subscriptions
Stephen Werner Terry schweren Duncan
farmer and Juan have each gifted a
subscription at joinpakman.com that pops
us up to 138 which is a delightful
delightful number and thanks to J.R dubs
resubbing on Twitch we're at 139. uh
guys I don't you can use any coupon code
it truly doesn't matter like uh here's
someone named way taller who signed up
with the code elements of bathrooms
beautiful I don't care which coupon code
people use it just really doesn't bother
me can I do one Whitney voicemail before
the debate starts you know before the
debate starts I just want to see what
other streams there are
oh I think I like this one better
let's see
yeah I think I like this stream better
let's see if we can
here
I just have a better feeling about this
one
there we go and
[Music]
and let's check out our audio care about
most immigration abortion rights gun
violence and how far we'll go to protect
our children at school all right let's
see if I can squeeze in a voicemail real
quick from Whitney here we go
so are we working
efforts
all right sorry guys the debate's
starting the Performing Arts
Arts sent Grand Valley in
Eden for the Texas
I am your host Britt Moreno anchor at
KXAN in Austin this debate is airing
live from El Paso to Tyler and from
Amarillo to Brownsville carried by 14
next star Media Group stations in Texas
as well as five partner TV stations and
we want you all to join in the
conversation on social media
txgov debate you'll see it there at the
bottom of your screen you're all here to
watch these two men share their vision
for the State of Texas asking the
questions tonight our panelists from
KSAT in San Antonio anchor Steve
spreester my colleague at kxin anchor
Sally Hernandez and from the Dallas
Morning News political writer gromer
Jeffers candidates let's briefly go over
the rules for tonight each candidate
will have 60 seconds for each question
if there are follow-ups candidates will
then have 30 seconds and there will be
up to 30 seconds levels at the end of
the debate each candidate 30 seconds for
closing statements and when your time is
up you're going to hear this Bell
and with that let's get started I'm
going to send it over to my colleague
Sally with the first question thank you
and again thank you both for being here
tonight I could tell it's going to be an
exciting night got a lot of questions to
ask you both but I just want to remind
you please pay attention to the time
cues this way you're not talking over
each other and I don't have to interrupt
you and our viewers at home can hear
your answers tonight
let's get to it immigration immigration
issues are especially relevant here in
the Rio Grande Valley for years U.S
Customs and Border Protection has ranked
it as the number one area for migrants
crossing illegally along the entire
southwestern border
many communities here have suffered
enormous monetary costs
Governor Abbott let's start with you and
you have 60 seconds with this question
what would you do to alleviate the
financial burden placed on these
communities he hasn't done and working
to respond to the disaster caused by the
body Administration that has caused such
an economic burden on these communities
farms and ranches are run over
communities are disrupted homes that are
invaded remember this just two years ago
we had one of the safest borders in
decades but under the body
Administration we have more people
coming across the border than ever in
the history of our country Texas has
responded by making sure that we have
the National Guard and DPS deployed
where they're making arrests and turning
back illegal immigrants as as well as
what we're doing to help local
communities by bussing them from the
area where border patrol is dropping
them off to Sanctuary cities in
northeastern parts of the country but
what we're doing is making sure that we
are keeping our community safe and this
is completely different than the way
things would be under Beto because he
said months ago there is no problem on
the border he said that he would reduce
immigration enforcement he even said
that 95 percent of people come across
the border illegally okay Mr O'Rourke I
wanted I want to give you a chance to
respond and let me just repeat the
question first for our viewers and for
you what would you do to alleviate the
financial burden placed on Border
communities related crossing over 60
seconds please what we just heard from
the governor is what we are likely to
hear over the course of this debate he's
going to blame people like President
Biden he's going to try to lie about my
record and he's going to distract from
his failures whether it's his failure to
keep the lights on in the grid his
failure to address school shootings or
his failure in Immigration we are eight
years into his time as governor and this
is what we have on our border in fact
four billion dollars into operation Lone
Star we're seeing not fewer but more
encounters at our border right now what
we need is a safe legal orderly path for
anyone who wants to come here to work to
join fam family or to seek Asylum if you
I'm just switching streams we finally
found like an actual good stream on an
operation Lone Star I have a follow-up
question about that about four billion
dollars in state funds has been directed
to the operation Lone Star border
security initiative uh the program is
seen as funding increase as recently as
this past July so the question governor
in 30 seconds if you can to answer this
should more money be allocated towards
operation Lone Star and if so Governor
how much well candidly we shouldn't have
to allocate any money for it because
this is all because of Joe Biden's
failure to do the president's job to
secure the Border because of Joe Biden's
failure and because it would be the same
pathway that Beto would take us down
speaking of which he talked about this
guest worker program he could have done
that had he won the race for the senate
or won the race for president that's not
a job for governor the job of Governor
is have to deal with the chaos caused by
the by Administration and its open
border policies that beta would
replicate
chaos things to go Governor Abbott right
now okay let me give you 15 seconds to
answer the question for me how much
money should be going toward operation
Lone Star and I'm telling you zero
dollars should be going to operation
Lone Star and that's what it would be if
we had a president who was enforcing the
immigration laws of the United States of
America Mr work I want to go over to you
30 seconds for this question it's the
same one should more money be allocated
towards operation can anyone count Joe
Biden mentions literally failed um the
numbers are in we're seeing not fewer
but more engagements at our border when
the governor spent 4 billion of our tax
dollars on what has turned out to be
political theater for his political
career he promised us that it would
deter people from coming to this country
we've only seen more people come now
they get a bus ride to Chicago or
Washington DC or New York we don't need
any more stunts we need Solutions we
need those coming here to follow our
laws we need to make sure our laws
following values I'll give you 15
seconds so these are efforts to protect
our state there is a record amount of
fentanyl coming across the border this
deadly we've Texas law enforcement has
seized enough fentanyl to kill every man
woman and child in the entire country
and this is because of Joe Biden I'm
sure you have a lot of questions a lot
of topics to get to and Steve has the
next one thank you Sally and thank you
gentlemen for both being here tonight
sorry to interrupt once more guys this
debate format is a disaster you can
learn nothing 15 second rebuttals come
on guys let them talk speaking at a
March rally in College Station
our guard members from Texas A M who are
on the border right now in Zapata and
Webb and Hidalgo County
parts of a solution in search of a
problem
a solution in search of a problem more
recently you told the Houston Chronicle
that you will put some troops on the
border as governor in 60 seconds can you
explain why your view on deploying
troops has seemingly changed
it hasn't I've actually been to Zapata
and Webb and Maverick counties and
listen to these members of the Guard who
had less than a week to say goodbye to
their families into their careers and
into their communities to be part of the
governor's political theater those
aren't my words those are their words so
far we've lost the lives of eight guard
members four of them have taken their
lives and four of them have died in
questionable circumstances none of whom
by the way was killed by anybody coming
in to this country these guard members
say they have no powers to arrest or
detain anybody ten thousand guard
members four billion dollars and it's
been a complete failure much as
everything that the governor has done
has been a failure for this state what
we need are solutions not more stunts
where we can have a strategic deployment
on a voluntary basis for guard members
let's do that I've been consistent on
that where we can partner with local
sheriffs with DPS Troopers let's do that
but we need to work on things like a
texas-based guest worker program to meet
labor needs in our communities and
ensure that our laws match our values
thank you Mr O'Rourke Governor I want to
talk to you you talked about migrants
and the bussing of migrants many migrant
Advocates and Democratic elected
officials have expressed concerns about
the treatment of migrants being bussed
from Texas to other states and cities
here's New York mayor Eric Adams talking
about that just last week yeah and when
we reached out to Governor Abbott and
stated can we coordinate can we identify
you know who's traveling here that we
don't have to guess this they refuse to
do so
the White House has called this a
political stunt Governor Abbott is this
a political stunt and has there been
coordination with the states and cities
these migrants are being taken to and if
not why not you have 60 seconds so this
operation began after meeting with local
officials uh sheriffs Mayors police
Chiefs and County judges they were
overrun with the number of migrants that
border patrol had dumped into to their
tiny little communities they needed
relief and busing was one of the ways of
providing them relief and thus began the
process of busting the migrants to
cities that self-identified as sanctuary
cities mayor Adams has never called my
office never talked to anybody in in my
Administration and so what he's saying
is just flat out false there has been
communication between non-governmental
organizations in Texas as well as the
ultimate location whether it be
Washington DC or New York but going back
to what Beto said he's what you showed
on video earlier was what happens
throughout this entire campaign where
Beto continues to flip-flop on issue
after issue after issue he's
flip-flopped on the border issue he's
flip-flopped on the energy issue such as
uh energy jobs and the great New Deal
he's flip-flopped on defunding the
police whether it's one even if this
were true I'd rather the guy who changes
his opinion than the guy who destroys
the state hold your office correct thank
you
Mr O'Rourke I want to follow up on this
you've called the busing of migrants a
political stun as well why shouldn't
Sanctuary cities share the burden of
what's happening on the Texas border you
have 30 seconds look I live on the
border no one cares more about the
security and safety of the Border than
those who are raising our children there
I also serve as a city council member
there and in my time working with law
enforcement working with state and
federal Partners we were able to help
make El Paso Texas one of the safest
cities in the United States of America
it's because we were looking at
Solutions instead of these stunts I just
want to remind everyone this guy's been
governor for eight years and this is
where we are today some of the worst
levels of Engagement encounters fentanyl
trafficking and human smuggling that
we've seen that's the results instead of
solutions stick to the time please thank
you Steve I got to respond to what he
just said Absolutely I'll give you I'll
give you 15 seconds El Paso the fact of
the matter is that El Paso mayor a
Democrat the El Paso city council
Democrats they are now bussing more
people than the state of Texas is
bussing and he's not calling them out
for them to every different program it
is it is apples to oranges and I'll tell
you this hateful rhetoric this treating
human beings as political pawns talking
about invasions
defending themselves that's how people
get killed at the Walmart in El Paso the
gentleman in hudspeth that we just
learned about yesterday this is
incredibly dangerous for Texas and it's
not reflective terrorists okay Governor
I want to give you 30 seconds to respond
to those charges sure I mean is is clear
you know that Beto just wants to
perpetuate the open border policy is it
mischaracterize exactly what's going on
there is no such policy the city of El
Paso because they were so overwhelmed by
Joe Biden's open border policies they
too are having to bust Magnus out of
their communities because they have no
way of keeping them there that's what
we're trying to do to help our local
communities and make sure that we are
going to lighten the loads for open
borders uh not the least of us who
actually live on the borders this is the
kind of science there's almost three
participants Abbott O'Rourke and the
bell for you governor and it's on the
bus in question these migrants are being
sent to states and cities with
Democratic Leadership why aren't these
migrants being sent to so-called
Sanctuary cities in republican-led
States like New Orleans or or Metro
Atlanta you have 30 seconds so again
because these cities of New York and
Washington D.C and Chicago are so large
and have the infrastructure that is
available they have the capability of
accommodating the number of migrants
that are being sent better than these
other cities that you talked about there
will be other cities in the future that
also will be on the receipts because we
will continue to have to move migrants
because Joe Biden continues to allow
more illegal immigrants to come into the
state of Texas thank you Governor my
colleague Romer Jeffers has the next
question thank you Steve and hello
gentlemen um good to see you both you
too grammar uh let's pivot now to the
topic of gun control following the
Uvalde Massacre many Community many
community members made this one specific
plea here's one student who survived the
shooting at Robb Elementary
you have to be 21 to buy a case of beer
but it's an 18 year old bought a gun to
kill kids that does not make sense no to
be clear that's a call to raise the age
limit to buy an AR-15 style weapon from
18 to 21. a republican governor in
Florida broke with the NRA to sign this
into law after the Parkland mass
shooting Mr Miss Governor Abbott you say
this can't be done in Texas Mr O'Rourke
you say it will be done if you're
elected can you please explain your
positions let's start with you Governor
Abbott you have 60 seconds first there's
no reason why a little girl like that
should ever have to say anything like
that there's a reason why these parents
are angry and they're rightfully angry
and I can feel their pain no share No
parent should lose a child and we want
to do everything we can to make sure
that does not happen we want to end
school shootings but we cannot do that
by making false promises he's against
school shootings he's making it clear
it's a law that will be upheld by the
Constitution to raise the age and here's
why the most recent Federal Court of
Appeals decision on this particular
issue said that it was unconstitutional
for a state to raise the age from 18 to
21 for a person to buy an AR-15 so any
attempt to try to to raise the age is
going to be met with it being overturned
so we need to get to the bottom of what
is really ailing our communities and
that is the mental health that is
leading people to engage in school
shootings and Texas is already
addressing that yeah just just a quick
follow-up Governor take 15 seconds to
answer this your former Attorney General
you you've never shied away from a legal
fight are you against this proposal
because you feel like it's
unconstitutional or you believe that
it's unnecessary you personally believe
that it's unnecessary purely from a
legal position based upon what that
court of appeals decision ruled and
import currently based upon what the
Supreme Court decision said in a June
opinion that changed the way that that
Parkland case was determined I know how
the Park Market was was determined
Florida is going to have its law
overturned because of this new Supreme
Court decision thank you Governor Mr
O'Rourke in 60 seconds can you uh please
explain your position on raising the age
limit to purchase AR-15 style weapons
I'm going to follow the lead of those
families from Uvalde that's who I'm
doing this for in fact many of them
drove more than five hours 280 miles to
be here today even though they're not
allowed in this theater because of the
governor's conditions because they want
to hold him accountable because that was
18 weeks since their kids have been
killed and not a thing has changed in
this state to make it any less likely
than any other child will meet the same
fate all we need is action and the only
person standing in our way is the
governor of the state of Texas in
Florida after the Parkland shootings it
was 23 days for that Republican Governor
to raise the age and in those states
where the age has been raised mass
shootings are down 80 percent so yes we
can raise the age to 21 and as Governor
I'll bring Republicans and Democrats
around the table to do that after all
these mass shootings this Governor has
done nothing except make it easier for
people who should not have a firearm to
carry them publicly and this is what we
get as a result we need change governor
have it the the last time you ran for
governor we asked you about red flag
laws and those are laws which could stop
an individual with uh potential
intention to harm others from purchasing
a gun and you said about that quote I
would not support a red flag law that
would take guns away from people without
due process now a lot has happened in
those four years are you open to
implementing red flag laws today you
have 30 seconds well let me tell you
what I support and I don't support but
what a support is making it a felony for
someone to lie on a background check I
signed that into law last year I approve
of expanding background checks to
include juvenile records also approve of
making it a crime for criminal gangs to
buy or to possess a gun but I'm still
against red flag laws for the reason
that it would deny a lawful he says the
issue is mental health
he's against red flag laws Mr O'Rourke
you have been criticized at times for
your positions on gun control including
this comment you made in 2019 while
running for president
hell yes we're going to take your AR-15
your AK-47 we're not going to allow it
to be used against our fellow Americans
anymore
but in February you told reporters in
Tyler that you were quote not interested
in taking anything away from anyone
so which is it uh Mr O'Rourke are you
for confiscating AR-15 style weapons or
not you have 30 seconds after losing 23
of my neighbors to somebody armed with a
weapon of war after talking to these
families who could only identify their
children in New Valley by the shoes that
they were wearing it's clear to me that
the only place that an AR-15 or an AK-47
makes sense is on a battlefield but as
governor of the state of Texas I need to
be focused on what we can get done
raising the minimum age of purchase to
21 we can get that done a red flag law
we'll get that done Universal background
checks we will get that done we'll make
progress and take action where this
Governor has failed thank you Mr Wolf so
just to be clear
yes or no are you for confiscating AR-15
style weapons I'm for making sure that
we make progress those families that I
was just with from Uvalde want us to
take action this is the common ground
I've listened to Republicans and
Democrats alike on this we can agree on
this much raise the age to 21. okay red
red flag law and Universal banking Mr
O'Rourke Steve has the next question
thank you gromer we want to focus in now
more on the Uvalde shooting
a gunman killed 19 children and two
adults its effects though go far beyond
Uvalde Mr O'Rourke I want you to speak
to parents of victims and really all
parents Statewide worried about their
children's safety at school what would
you do if elected to prevent this from
happening again you have 60 seconds just
like you I'm a parent with Amy we're
raising Ulysses and Molly and Henry in
El Paso and we are well aware that it's
been 18 weeks and this Governor has not
lifted a finger to make it any less
likely that any of our kids will meet
that same fate we need change the
governor just talked about mental health
care we are dead last in the nation when
it comes to Mental Health Care access
and he took 211 million dollars from the
mental health care budget of the State
of Texas he'll talk about police funding
he failed to fund the Police radios in
evality even when that Police Department
asked for them and you know what those
radios failed on that day I want every
parent out there to know that the lives
of your children are more important to
me than the NRA or any special interests
or any other political consideration I
will prioritize them ahead of everything
else and we will take action and we will
make progress we'll bring Republicans
Democrats Independents alike together
and we'll get the job done where this
Governor has failed to do so
Governor Abbott
to you now the families of the victims
the Uvalde School District the Uvalde
County Commissioners the Uvalde city
council all asked for you to call a
special session in the wake of the
tragedy you did not despite calling them
on several other issues in the past can
you explain why you didn't call a
special session you have 60 seconds I
will but I must first respond to what we
have to respond to every single day
Beto's campaign continues to spew lies
and false information he said two things
that are completely false he said that
we're we're last in mental health care
the fact of the matter is Texas is now
27th in mental health care because a
funding that I provided Texas has
provided more than 25 billion dollars
for mental health care in the last three
sessions he also said that we did not
fund Police radios in Uvalde completely
false we provided 1.6 million dollars
for you vality alone for their police
radio systems since I've been Governor
so Beto continues to provide false
information what I want to make sure
that the leaders in uvaldino is is as
we've shown we don't need to call a
special session in order to take action
for six consecutive days after the
shooting took place I issued directives
to make school safer and respond to the
emergency in New Valley and then I
remain engaged with the mayor with the
local leaders it could have been worse
that's what you told those families
that's what we told that community and
they've done nothing to help them
sure we're not done with this topic yet
so you will have your say but but
Governor I want to follow up with you
there's a there's a regular session
coming up in January will you make
school safety an emergency item for
lawmakers when they meet you have 15
seconds absolutely just like I did in
past sessions that this is going to be
an emergency item over the summer I
requested special legislative committees
to begin working already so that they
will have ready when we begin the
session to address the broader base
issue across the entire state of Texas
emergency
why wait till the next year Mr O'Rourke
a question for you now
leading cause of death for children and
teenagers in the state why are you
waiting to save lives we need to move on
we've had a lot of topics we want to get
to but we want to stay on Uvalde because
there's still some questions that we
have here so I appreciate you what is
happening within your time uh Mr
O'Rourke Valley School District Police
Chief Peter Arredondo who led the
initial law enforcement response at Robb
Elementary was fired
is there anyone else who should be held
accountable for the mistakes made in
that hallway in Rob Elementary that day
you have 30 seconds the governor said it
himself in an interview to gromer
Jeffers last month there should be
accountability up and down the ballot
beginning with Greg Abbott I think he
has lost the right to serve this state
in the most important position of public
trust furthermore we know that there
were 91 DPS Troopers for whom he is
responsible who were on the other side
of an unlocked door some for more than
70 minutes there is a complete failure
to hold people responsible accountable
those families still do not have justice
as Governor I will make it my priority
thank you Mr O'Rourke Governor now to
you there was it go ahead I'll give you
15 seconds if you want to respond to
what well I was I was going to answer
your question the question I thought you
were going to ask me but I've got seven
seconds to criticize Joe Biden and then
eight to respond you said this
but the reality is as horrible as
what happened
it could have been worse
it could have been worse you heard sure
bring it up you later said you were
misled about what happened inside Rob
Elementary if my memories serves me
right that was the day after so we were
just moments after what had happened
who misled you
and will they be held accountable you
have 30 seconds everyone in that
briefing room that provided me the
information about what law enforcement
did what that comment was based upon was
information by law enforcement about all
the children and all the other
classrooms that they evacuated during
the time when the shooter was on the
campus what they did not tell me at the
time however was that there were dozens
if not more of other law enforcement
that were hanging around in the hallway
for open it definitely could have been
worse he's insisting and also he was
advised by people who kept information
from him that shooter which is what they
were supposed to do and because they
failed to do that there does need to be
accountability not just for Pete
Arredondo but also for local law
enforcement DPS officers or under
investigation as we speak right now
there needs to be accountability for law
enforcement at every level for not
following the Columbine protocol
you won't be sure to hold DPS Troopers
accountable so yeah in a word yes but
second there are at least seven who are
under investigation as we speak right
now two of whom are on suspension as we
speak right now and so we I expect DPS
officers and law enforcement across the
state to follow the combine protocol
Governor they give me a buck stops on
your desk you blame everyone else you
blame Joe Biden for everything we need
to move on you believe to move on on
topics
Sally will ask the next question I do
and I think you're both going to want to
talk about this next traffic
it's the topic of abortion a recent next
star Emerson College and the hill pool
shows more than a half of those poll
sayings they are more likely to vote in
this election because of the overturning
of Roe versus way
you both are very outspoken on this
issue but what I want to do tonight is
really drill down on specifics
Governor Abbott you recently sat down
with my friend gromer over here and you
talked about what women can do if they
are victims of rape or incest and here's
a clip of that interview
those victims can access health care
immediately as well as to report it both
of those have very meaningful
consequences by accessing Health Care
immediately they can get the Plan B pill
that can prevent a pregnancy from
occurring in the first place
some Health Care Advocates say emergency
contraceptive guys they'll allow you to
report that you were raped okay why
aren't you thanking them women to afford
and Trauma could prevent them from
taking emergency contraception in the
time frame that it's effective so
Governor we're going to start with you
with these concerns that I just laid out
is emergency contraception a viable
alternative to abortion for victims of
rape and incest then you have 60 seconds
Sir so to directly answer the topics
that you raised on the availability of
it is incumbent upon the state of Texas
to make sure that it is readily
available for those who are victims of
sexual assault or survivors of sexual
assault the state of Texas pays for that
whether it be at a hospital at a clinic
or or for someone who gets a
prescription because of it and so not
only is it should be readily available
but the state of Texas is going to pay
for it to make sure that it is available
for them
but Governor 30 seconds or you know I'll
give you I'll give you 30 seconds to
answer this one
I still want to know is Plan B the
alternative when it comes to somebody
who is pregnant from rape or incest
well it depends on what you mean by
alternative an alternative obviously uh
is uh to do what we can to assist and
Aid the victim and that is to help get
them Plan B Works within a couple days
you know as you guys all know many women
don't know they're pregnant for four to
six weeks they're gonna to know that the
state uh throughout our alternatives to
abortion program provides living
assistance baby supplies all kinds of
things that can help them also we've
increased funding for prenatal and
postpartum thank you Governor Mr
O'Rourke we're going to stay on the
topic of abortion here Governor Abbott
has said that you support abortion on
demand do you support any limit on when
a woman can't have an abortion in 60
seconds for this question this election
is about reproductive Freedom if you
care about this you need to turn out and
vote I will fight to make sure that
every woman in Texas can make her own
decisions about her own body her own
future and her own health care and I
will work with the legislature and my
fellow Texans to return us to the
standard that Texas women won in the
first place Roe versus weight that's the
standard that answers your question but
I've got to respond to this this this
silliness on Plan B this comment he made
about eliminating rape in the state of
Texas this is an attack on women more
women have been raped in the state of
Texas than any other state there are 3
000 untested rape kits at DPS
headquarters meaning that our building
our ability to bring rapists to justice
has declined by half on this Governor's
watch and it's arguable that rapists
enjoy more victims because more more
rights under Greg Abbott than their
victims do because they can sue the
families of their victims if they help
their victim get an abortion and and be
able to win a ten thousand dollar bounty
in the process Mr work I'll give you a
chance to respond Governor 30 seconds so
once again I'm going to be doing this a
lot I have to point out a misstatement
by Beto I signed a law that eliminated
the rape kit test backlog at the Texas
Department of Public Safety uh as it
concerns abortion listen bezel's
position is the most extreme because he
not only supports abortion of a fully
developed child to the very last second
before birth he's even against providing
medical care at this point the baby who
survives an abortion he is for unlimited
abortion at taxpayer expense that's not
true it's completely alive
um I never said that and and no one
thinks that in in the state of Texas
he's saying this because he signed the
most extreme abortion ban in America no
exception for rape no exception for
incest it begins at conception and it's
taking place in a state that is at the
epicenter of a maternal mortality crisis
thanks to Greg Abbott three times as
deadly for black women I will fight to
make sure that every woman makes their
own decisions about her own body her own
future and her own health care that's
what most of us Republicans and
Democrats in this state believe Mr work
just in 15 seconds is there a limit that
you support on women getting an abortion
that limit was decided in 1973 through a
victory that Jane Rowe and Linda coffee
and Sarah Weddington won before an
all-male United States Supreme Court I
want us to return to that it was the law
of the land for nearly 50 years until we
had the most extreme abortion
has the next question thanks thanks
Sally uh let's move to law enforcement
Mr O'Rourke you have been accused by
Governor Abbott of supporting efforts to
defund police he may have mentioned it
uh tonight actually here's a chance for
you to set the record straight do you
support measures to defund police you
have 60 seconds of course I don't and
and no one does but let's look at my
record I think that's the best thing to
look at and then we'll look at the
governors on the El Paso city council I
raised police salaries 12 percent in the
six years that I served here there in
Congress I funded 11 billion dollars to
local and state law enforcement across
this country including in Texas I want
to fund law enforcement fund training so
that everyone is treated equally under
the law and I want there to be
accountability for when those officers
abuse the public trust but let's look at
what Greg Abbott's done when police and
law enforcement begged him not to sign
permitless carry because it allows
anyone to carry a gun in public without
a background check he turned his back on
them did it anyhow homicides have gone
up 50 percent and we now have gun
violence as a leading cause of death for
Abbott will blame Biden for the
homicides right when the availity police
department asked for funding he turned
his back on them he is not doing what
keeps us safe that's why you see the
level of rape violent crime and homicide
up on Greg Abbott's watch Jessica a
quick uh follow-up Mr O'Rourke can you
take 15 seconds to answer this uh after
the summer of 2020 did you uh voice
support for cities that cut their police
budgets Minneapolis comes to mind did
you support those efforts what I
supported and what I continue to support
is full funding for law enforcement full
funding that includes training to ensure
that we're treating everyone equally
under the law and we definitely need
accountability and Justice if someone
abuses the power of life and death over
our fellow citizens thank you without
accountability we lose the ability to
keep our communities thank you Mr Aurora
Governor Abbott you have spoken about uh
the growing crime in Texas and your
commercials and on the campaign Trail
you have been governor for more than
seven years so why is crime up don't you
bear some of the responsibility because
if I fully answer that question let me
first you have 60 seconds by the way let
me reply and that is once again Beto
misleads by saying that we denied Uvalde
Police Department any money we not we've
answered every call they've ever made to
make sure they have whatever funding
they need and Beto clearly said that in
response to Minneapolis that he supports
their idea of defunding and dismanting
dismantling police I gotta add this he
didn't say a word to criticize the City
of Austin that defunded their police by
more than 100 million million dollars
the law I passed will prevent any City
from defunding the police because in
Texas we support our Law Enforcement
Officers period the reason why there's
been a rising crime in some areas
grammar is because of another issue
we're working on and that's what's
happening in Harris County and some
other counties where in Harris County
they have these easy bail policies that
Beto supports which is cashless bail
that is letting dangerous criminals such
as people recently convicted or murdered
last year back out on the streets now
who killed a police officer recently in
Houston Texas governor take 15 seconds
to answer this again you've been
governor for seven years crime is up do
you bear any responsibility for that so
let me again explain what happened in
Austin after they they defunded the
police the year after that they had the
highest number of murders ever in Harris
County where they have this easy Bell
policy wow in the past couple of years
there have been hundreds of people
killed by people let out on bail who had
been previously arrested for murder
thank you Governor our next topic comes
from one of our his answer is no he
doesn't take any responsibility yes
Gomer thank you so much candidates I
have our first viewer question for you
and just so you know we use this as a
jumping off point to then craft our own
question for you so here is Douglas
Tyler out of Hayes County with his
question Douglas
to ensure that there's not an
out in there like we had during the
winter of 2021. how would you increase
the generation capacity and reliability
oh God is it time for Texas to face
reality and join the rest of the country
in the Cooperative grid system it kind
of is
okay clearly Douglas asked a lot of
questions about the grid many Texans
have similar questions so we're going to
break them down one by one and for that
I will send it back over to my colleague
Steve thank you Brit and I want to thank
Douglas for that question and and
Governor Abbott first for you following
the outages in February of 2021 the
legislature passed 18 different pieces
of legislation aimed at improving the
grid an energy expert Ed hers from the
University of Houston said last month
quote no question the Grid's better than
it was at this time last year the
governor says it's never been more
reliable but if you're getting up off
the floor any kind of movement is better
than what it was end quote Governor
Abbott what do you make of that
assessment of the state grid are you
confident in its reliability you have 60
seconds very confident and in fact even
guaranteed the power would stay on
before we faced that winter afterwards
when Beto was campaigning saying that
the grid was going to fail in the winter
and summer his campaign hopes fell apart
because the laws that I signed did
secure the grid ever since I signed
those reform laws no Texan has lost
power because of the Texas power grid
and know this Steve and that is this
summer we set 11 new all-time records
for heat time and again the power grid
was able to keep up and it's because of
the reforms we were able to make Abbott
personally set a record for air
conditioning use in his house more
reliable than ever before to go ahead
and answer Douglas's question which we
appreciate one reason why it's more
reliable is because we have greater
power available to us and the greater
ability by the Public Utilities
Commission to address it but also we are
going to be adding more Renewable Power
I mean non-renewable power such as
natural gas to make sure that the power
stays on thank you governor Mr O'Rourke
same question you know there hasn't been
any major issues with the grid with
outages since the winter of 2021 what do
you make of the changes that Governor
Abbott and led the legislature put in to
make the grid more reliable they say
more reliable what would you do
differently you have 60 seconds Governor
Abbott's grid failure is part of a
pattern over these last eight years
warned about for example School violence
and gun violence specifically against
children does nothing warned about
problems within Child Protective
Services our foster care program does
nothing and it gets worse worn before
February 2021 that we had problems in
the grid he did nothing when the
blackout started he ordered the price of
electricity pegged at its highest
allowable rate gas started trading at
200 times what it had sold for the day
before now we are all paying 45 bucks
more on average in our monthly utility
bills it's the Abbott tax that all of us
pay 700 of our fellow Texans lost their
lives because of his is incompetence and
his uninability to do what was necessary
before February of 2021 and the kicker
is the grid is still not fixed just ask
Toyota they stopped their third shift in
San Antonio because it was drawing too
much power we had three conservation
notices this summer we are not ready for
this next winter we need a governor
who's going to do the right thing
thank you Mr award Governor I'll give
you 30 seconds sure all betso does is
fair Monger on this issue when in
reality the grid is more resilient and
reliable than it's ever been yeah but
that's still not very good importantly
Texans need to know this and that is
after Yuri after the reforms that we
passed Texas has one of the lowest
electricity prices in the country far
below the national average and less than
half of what the electricity price is in
California
it's one of the fastest growing costs in
the state of Texas and when you look at
our higher energy bills our property
taxes 20 billion more under Greg Abbott
you see that he's the largest driver of
inflation in the state of Texas right
now I'll give you 15 seconds Governor so
it just makes this stuff up because
that's all again the the reality is the
electricity call us in Texas remains one
of the lowest in the entire United
States of America and far lower than the
national average ask the people who are
paying it thank you gentlemen Sally has
the next question got to talk about
education tonight gentlemen okay there's
a lot of teachers who are watching and
who would like to know the answer to
this next question Texas school
districts are hampered by an
unprecedented teacher retention crisis a
Texas teacher Workforce report reveals
there are more than 13
000 new teachers in Texas for the start
of the
2010-2011 school year okay look at that
number flash forward to the 2019-2020
school year less than half of those
teachers remained former teachers cited
everything from pay to burnout to safety
as problems Mr O'Rourke I want to start
with you for this next question how are
you going to keep qualified teachers in
the classroom when you have 60 seconds I
mentioned earlier that Amy and our
raising our three children in El Paso
where they attend the world-class public
schools there and we know firsthand the
important job that those Educators do
and I want every educator out there to
know that I've got your back and I'm
going to make sure that we pay you
enough not to work a second or a third
job because of Greg Abbott our teachers
are underpaid on average by 7 500 a year
I'm going to ensure that you have more
valuable classroom time to connect with
those kids so we're going to stop the
star test and allow you to focus on
drawing forth that Lifelong Love of
learning from every child before you for
our retired teachers I'll make sure you
have a cost of living adjustment every
single year going forward you haven't
had one in 18 years eight of those on
Greg Abbott's watch and most importantly
I will treat you with the dignity and
respect that you have earned and that
you deserve you sacrifice and give so
much to our kids into this state we need
to make sure we're holding up our end of
the bargain as Governor I will 30
seconds to respond to this follow-up you
say that you do support teachers do you
support giving them a pay raise if
you're elected and if so how are you
going to pay for that absolutely I want
to give them a pay raise I want to make
sure again that they're not working that
second or third job what I propose to do
and as Republican and Democratic support
for this is raise the state's share of
school funding right now we ask property
taxpayers the homeowners and renters out
there to shoulder the majority of the
burden I want to make sure that the
state is shouldering its fair share we
do that we can reduce your property
taxes at home and provide more funding
for our schools increase teacher pay and
more per pupil funding in every District
in Texas thank you Mr Governor Abbott
same question how are you going to keep
qualified teachers in the classroom as a
question can you answer that for me in
30 seconds I will but I I gotta say that
raise the state share of Education
funding is exactly what we did both in
2019 and 2021 in fact I provided more
funding for Education than any governor
in Texas history I provided more funding
for teacher pay raises than any governor
in Texas history as We Gather here
tonight Sally the per pupil funding in
the state of Texas is at the highest
there's ever been so we will work with
the teachers to make sure I created a
new program
I'll tell you about I'm going to give
you 30 more seconds this is your 60
second answer go ahead I created a new
program have more time that provides a
six-figure
for teachers more than a hundred
thousand dollars it was used very
effectively and broadly in the Dallas
County or Dallas Independent School
District area uh and is catching on
around the state if teachers will
dedicate themselves to be these Master
Teachers they will be able to earn a
six-figure salary Educators watching
tonight 15 seconds or less are you going
to give them a raise if you are
re-elected yes we it just as we have
given them a pay raise in the past we
will continue those pay raises going
forward he's been governor for eight
years how many opportunities did he get
to answer the question against their
National counterparts for people funding
let me give you 14 seconds go ahead I'll
give you 15 seconds but we can't talk
over each other go ahead per pupil
funding in the state is four thousand
dollars less than our counterparts
across the country educational
attainment is at an all-time low
pre-pandemic in the average fourth grade
classroom in Texas
um most of those fourth graders could
not read advice of those teachers time
is up we're gonna go to groomer for the
next question thank you thank you Sally
at um the next two questions are
personal questions directed to each of
you only there will be no opportunities
for rebuttals wow so let's start with
you Governor Abbott University of
Houston political scientist Brandon
rottinghouse said the following quote in
Texas politics it's adopt or die Greg
Abbott didn't start his career as a
right-wing Republican but he certainly
ended up there Governor Abbott you
signed a law Banning nearly all
abortions without exceptions for rape or
incest and a law allowing the
permanentless carry of firearms critics
including some members of your own party
say you have moved too far to the right
have you moved too far to the right
Governor you have 67 no I haven't well
let's look at the issues that you
brought up and and that is for one
as a Catholic and my wife and I we've
been pro-life our entire lives
so much so that it grew even stronger
when we adopted our daughter on the the
day she was born
I was the very first person to hold her
after she was born and I've seen
firsthand the power that adoption can
have and it just further strengthened my
belief I held my daughter too when she
was born but it didn't make me stupid
possible seeing how it can happen so
successfully I want others to be able to
have that same sense of joy not only
that my wife and I have had but also
that our daughter has had
in general one thing that we've been
able to achieve across the entire state
of Texas we've ensure that we provide
opportunity for everybody government as
we get here tonight Texas ranks number
one in jobs created by black business
owners and jobs created by Hispanic
women business owners Governor Abbott
just 10 more seconds
have you move too far to the right
though in recent years from what I tried
to explain to you grammar is that I'm
governing from principles I'm not
looking at changing and constantly
flip-flopping positions like other
people do I'm governing from my
principles thank you thank you Governor
Abbott Mr O'Rourke you served as a
congressman from West Texas from 2013 to
2018. since then you had a close but
unsuccessful run for Senate against Ted
Cruz in 2018 two years later in 2020 you
had a unsuccessful run for president now
you're running for governor
why have you run for so many different
offices is it about ambition
or public service you have 60 Seconds
you know I feel so lucky that through so
much of my life I've had the opportunity
to serve others as a small business
owner in El Paso Texas creating High
skill high-wage high value jobs in our
community as a member of the city
council as a member of Congress on the
house Veterans Affairs committee
delivering for those who put their lives
on the line for this country for all of
us it has been the honor of my lifetime
and now to run to be able to overcome
these failures that we see in Texas
right now whether it's a grid that
doesn't work teachers who are leaving
the profession by the thousands leading
the nation a number of school shootings
being able to deliver for people who are
counting on us at this moment of truth
to make sure that we come through and
it's not just me and it's not just my
political party there are hundreds of
thousands of people across the state of
Texas who want change and are working
for it and it's my honor to be able to
lead this campaign and to serve as the
next governor of this state to make sure
that we deliver for them
uh thank you Mr O'Rourke uh let's go
back to Brit now for another topic
inspired by a viewer question yes
another viewer question for you tonight
candidates this is one of the worst
debates I've ever seen from an
organization and format perspective just
terrible Nation viewer it's from Missy
Pena out of New Braunfels here's Missy
what are your plans to help get mortgage
rates under control and make sure that
housing stays affordable for everyone
two of them oh this should be
interesting had in 0809 what's a
governor going to do about mortgage
rates sure
now we have our own question that
includes things on property taxes and
for that I will send it over to Steve
thank you Britain thank you Missy for
that great question you know property
taxes make up a hefty amount of most
people's mortgages in the state of Texas
I want to ask you this question for
property taxes are made people's
mortgages what are they talking about
the largest property tax cut in State
history that does not relieve the
long-term property tax burden that many
Texas residents feel
how would you provide long-term property
tax relief you have 60 seconds you know
about the the governor's proposal you
have to ask yourself where this guy's
been for the last eight years people
across the state are hurting are they
talking about escrow mortgage is
principal interest and PMI if required I
know some people escrow property taxes
but what kind of a question is that
latest driver of inflation in the state
of Texas this is how we can turn it
around one let's expand Medicaid we'll
go from a state that's at least insured
to one where everyone can see a doctor
or be able to fill a prescription it
will also reduce our property taxes
because right now you are on the hook
for uncompensated Indigent care two
let's up the share of State spending for
public Ed I talked about it earlier the
state spends 40 percent local property
taxpayers 60 under my leadership we'll
get that to 50 50. reduce the pressure
on local property taxpayers and third
let's make sure that there's property
tax fairness corporations in this state
are not paying their fair share that
means all of us pay more thank you sir
Governor Abbott I want to ask you the
same question how do you provide
long-term property tax relief you also
have 66 property tax relief is Central
to this election and to Texans at home
home just like Missy and know this
there's only one person on this stage
tonight Who's Ever Raised property taxes
and that is Beto Beto the framing of the
question is pathetic that just the
property taxes have to go down maybe
they're high maybe they're low maybe
they're just right but those taxes pay
for schools and so many other things and
so the real question is what else do you
want to give up in a state where most
things are dead last has done and we
will continue to do is to drive down the
ability of the the local governments for
me from being able to raise taxes and
I'm the only one with a bold vision for
actually cutting property taxes as you
pointed out because of our strong
economy in Texas we have a budget
surplus of 27 billion dollars I want to
use at least half of that 27 billion
dollars to drive down property tax rates
Steve it can be done in a long-term
basis if we use that to lower the school
property tax component thank you sir you
raised my name in that and yeah okay
I'll give you 15 seconds thank you like
many local leaders we have to deal with
unfunded mandates sent down by Greg
Abbott that's our Mental Health Care
System where the county jails are the
largest provider of mental health care
services are schools as Governor I'll
make sure that we expand Medicaid so we
reduce that demand and up the share of
State spending that's how we get that
done I want to move on because this is
an important topic and we've got a lot
of things we want to try to do we're
finally getting power Mr work you say
you would take the burden off property
tax owners by creating other revenue
streams most notably legalizing
marijuana expanding Medicaid and closing
loopholes enjoyed by commercial property
owners but but how will you get those
proposals through a
republican-controlled legislature 30
seconds
Republicans and Democrats alike across
the state want to make sure that we
reduce property taxes I think we all
have a vested interest in that outcome
they also agree on Common Sense
bipartisan Solutions expanding Medicaid
all that means is getting 10 billion
dollars back of our federal income taxes
to this state to reduce our property
taxes why Greg Abbott has not done it
when every border state has is beyond me
making sure that we legalize marijuana
so we no longer spend half a billion
dollars locking people up and forego
another half billion dollars in Revenue
again makes no sense thank you let's
legalize marijuana we need to move on
because I want to make sure we give the
governor a chance to answer my next
question your campaign team has said
since taking office property taxes
they're too busy sticking to the format
to let anyone actually answer questions
Pace with Rising property values that
increase the taxes homeowners pay how do
you solve this problem without
introducing additional revenue streams
you have 30 seconds sure so one way that
we have reduced property taxes is
through those Homestead exemptions uh
another way that we've done it is by
buying down the property tax rate at the
school district level and what I propose
to do with this 13.5 billion dollars if
not more is to drive down those property
tax rates even further my goal is to
eliminate the school property tax that's
imposed in the state of Texas so that
people can genuinely own their own home
without being taxed out of it Mr
O'Rourke I want to give you 15 seconds
he's eight he's had eight years to get
this done if it's such a good idea why
are we talking about another four years
to accomplish that I will reduce your
property taxes as Governor this guy has
has raised them by 20 billion dollars
forty percent increase since he first
took office you want more property taxes
vote for Greg Abbott
Governor I'm going to give you 15
seconds so anybody who knows anything
knows the state does not raise property
taxes the only reason why it would have
gone up is because evaluations that
would mean that I get credit for the
biggest enrichment that people have had
I will not take that one thing we have
to do to add on top of it we need to
reduce the appraisals we've got to
completely change the appraisal system
thank you sir we're running out of time
let's actually throw it over to Brit now
thank you and thank you gentlemen you
made it folks we're out of time we have
for questions tonight and now it's time
for your closing statements so Mr
O'Rourke we'll start with you tonight 30
seconds for your closing statement your
time starts now thank you look I don't
think that Greg Abbott wakes up wanting
to see children shot in their schools or
for the grid to fail but it's clear that
he's incapable or unwilling to make the
changes necessary to prioritize the
lives of our fellow Texans that's why
it's on all of us to make sure that we
have change at The Ballot Box this
November 8th I'll keep your lights on
I'll make sure that I keep your kids
safe we'll reduce property taxes and
will prioritize the lives of each and
every single Texan in the state Mr
O'Rourke thank you so much now Governor
Abbott your 30 seconds Starts Now Texas
ranks number one for the most new jobs
added since you've reelected me we're
number one for Blue Ribbon Schools
number one for tier one research
universities and number one in so many
categories I'm running for reelection to
keep Texas number one to cut your
property taxes to secure the border to
keep dangerous criminals Behind Bars and
to keep deadly fentanyl off our streets
together we will keep Texas number one
Governor Abbott thank you so much and
that concludes our debate tonight I want
to thank the candidates and our
moderators for being here with us
tonight and for participating I also
want to thank the University of Texas
Rio Grande Valley for hosting us here in
South Texas tonight up next you will be
able to watch the Texas governor's race
post debate speech now you can watch
this online or right here if you don't
see it check your local listing thank
you so much for joining us tonight and
to all of Texas good night and take care
what a nightmare debate I mean honestly
just just like a terrible debate really
really really bad
um the format was bad just everything
about it was bad
um it's like what's the point of the
debate if you just obsess with an
arbitrary format and you don't let
anybody actually talk about the
questions
um
I I don't even know what to tell you
guys I really don't
um listen thanks for stopping by I don't
know how much we learned other than
Abbott really is horrible
uh do we want to do 1.5 million tonight
like I mean I'll just keep going if if
we think we want to do 1.5 million
YouTube subscribers tonight I'll hang
we're down to like the last 1300.
but
um
I don't know maybe that's going to be
more of a tomorrow thing we've got the
Trump rally coming up tomorrow what do
people think
oh people are saying tonight
someone says they'd subscribe if I play
a Whitney voicemail
um I'll try a Whitney boy all right yeah
we were gonna do a Whitney voicemail
before
um
let's see where was that Whitney
voicemail all right let's see let's see
where we're at at the end of the
voicemail
so are we looking up about
different diseases that people might
have where there's like no evidence and
I don't understand calling certain
things a disease because
I just feel like if there's physical
whoa the voicemail is somehow pumping
Subs look at that and for something
inside the brain that you could see like
there would obviously be photographs and
stuff and people
uh you know sharing it with the doctor's
office like this is what's going on
inside of your brain
but
do you think that it's just like oh well
it reaches a certain point where it's
just like too difficult to argue with
somebody and so they call it a disease
I guess she's talking about
psychosomatic illness I don't know
thanks to graveborn for gifting 10
subscriptions on YouTube by the way I
really appreciate that and uh also thank
you to S Prez with oh wow folks s Prez
just dumped in a hundred dollar Super
Chat and it says everyone watching
please make sure you are subscribed that
is a beautiful message what do you think
do we do
1.499 tonight and then we call it and
then we go for 1.5 on tomorrow's Trump
rally stream
I don't know what everybody thinks
um
let's see I'll play a Troy York
voicemail to see if that titillates
anybody uh this is Wally Jackson again
yes one of your favorites it's not Wally
Jackson it's Troy York the right wing
trolls um I am calling your telegram
again I you may say I'm insistent but
the fact is you're insistent in your
lives and propaganda against Mr Trump Mr
DeSantis Mr Jim Jordan and it needs to
be confronted called out
um
and I will do so I just want to make
mention though that Mark Dice has joined
salty cracker and he has done another
January 6th video eviscerating
um your buddy and scumbag communist
Jamie Raskin I I don't care what Mark
Dice says I don't know how else to
explain it to people
your communist duck legs okay nice trip
it kind of happens to be great in other
countries yeah no kidding because
they're letting the Communists walk all
over the world
oh thank you so much dear God all right
guys we're gonna call it all right I
appreciate everybody who joined me I I
don't think I uh I just can't do it I
can't do it so we're gonna push for 1.5
million tomorrow night live live live
live during the Trump rally stream next
week There's even more debates coming up
next week let me see which ones are
coming up next week
next week we've got uh JD Vance versus
Tim Ryan remember JP right JD Mandel
we've also got Mark Kelly versus Blake
Masters there's a lot of really really
good debates next week extraordinary
extraordinary debates all right so let's
uh on Twitch we're gonna go over and
raid our friend Anthony fantano that'll
do it for me we'll see everybody back
here real soon